thank you for joining us at noon I'm
John langler we start with breaking news
two people killed early this morning and
Metro Police say it happened during a
gun sale the scene in apartment near
Craig and Las Vegas Boulevard up in the
Northeast Valley Madison Kimbrough is
there live at the scene with the latest
details Madison good afternoon
yeah 9-1-1 was notified just before 5 30
this morning of two men that are shot
we're going to take a closer look at the
apartment complex that we're at right
now that's happening at the Rubik's
apartments near Craig and Las Vegas
Boulevard Metro says officers went into
an apartment and found two men lying on
the floor both with gunshot wounds
Medics arrived and declared one man dead
at the scene the other was taken to UMC
and then died shortly after Metro Police
saying it all happened during an
apparent gun sale
two individuals came to the apartment to
purchase a firearm
during the negotiations of that firearm
they decided they did not want to
purchase it they just wanted to take it
without the without paying for it
police telling us a struggle in suit for
that weapon and that's when the shots
were fired as of now everyone involved
in the incident is accounted for